en irak des milliers de manifestants
défilent dans les rues de nadjaf après
l'attentât qui a fait plus de 80 morts
et 200 blessés
quatre suspects ont été arrêtés seraient
des liens avec al qaïda élèves et
enseignants reprennent le chemin de
l'école chacun s'y prépare aujourd'hui à
paris quelques assemblées générales et
collages des affiches alors que l'on
s'affaire dans les magasins pour l'achat
des dernières fournissent le prix des
cigarettes devrait augmenter de 18 à 20%
dès le mois d'octobre les fabricants
sont décidés à répercuter la hausse de
taxation décidé par le parlement
les buralistes sont inquiets et
attendent les aides de l'état et puis
l'athlétisme l'espoir de médaille
féminine pour yanis barber cfl et
championne du monde 200 longueur est en
cours de journal nous assisterons relais
4 x 100 m le suspense est intact
madame monsieur bonsoir en irak 24
heures après le sanglant attentat devant
la mosquée de nadjaf
il est bien difficile de mesurer
l'ampleur des conséquences de cet acte
terroriste qui s'est produit dans l'un
des hauts lieux sacrés du schisme la
tension est extrême
l'attaqué est attribuée à des partisans
de l'ancien président saddam hussein et
pour aimanter les différentes
communautés du pays entre elles avec un
risque de déstabilisation aujourd'hui
quatre personnes deux erreurs tient et
deux saoudiens ont été arrêtés ils
pourraient appartenir au réseau al qaïda
sur place nos envoyés spéciaux
stéphane breitner sujet cela apparemment
un problème de diffusion de ce sujet qui
doit venir de nadjaf en irak je pense
que nous avons pu rétablir la ligne
pas un cri
mais une rumeur qui monte autour des
ruines qui ont enseveli les leurs des
milliers de fidèles se recueille sur les
portes de la mosquée fermée au public
d'autres se prosternent les voiles
interrompu on veut nous y faire entrer à
l'intérieur c'est le cheikh jaber qui
mène la visite ici rien n'a bougé
comme si le temps s'était arrêté hier à
14h30 sur le toit il y a encore des
couvertures et des restes de cadavres
vous pouvez imaginer la grandeur de ce
crime des morceaux de tôle les tapis de
prière sans dessus dessous et des
centaines de chaussures oublié par les
fidèles dans leur fuite
seuls les strates de l'ayatollah y
rester un teint la garonne les gens
couraient partout ils ne savaient plus
par où sortir les familles ont même
laissé leurs enfants certains ont été
piétinées à côté du tombeau du prophète
voilà la police irakienne qui vient
faire ses constatations en silence comme
l'ambiance qui règne dans cet immense
cour près des portes la douleur vient de
l'extérieur
nous avons perdu celui qui combattait
saddam hussein et c'est sans aucun doute
l'oeuvre de ce dictateur cela va être
difficile de vivre en paix parce que
c'est le peuple irakien tout entier qui
est atteint dehors les cortèges funèbres
se succèdent devant la mosquée moment de
communion mais aussi de coller ce sont
nos martyrs maintenant c'est à cause de
la mairie qui lie à tous ces crimes en
irak
c'est allah qui nous vengera de ces
assassins dans le plus grand cimetière
d'irak 95 nouveaux corps ont rejoint les
autres depuis hier depuis ce matin la
vie s'est arrêtée à nadjaf puisque un
deuil de trois jours a été décrété la
grande cérémonie funèbre en l'honneur de
moi mais d'hakim n'aura pas lieu avant
la semaine prochaine
le corps de l'ayatollah n'ayant toujours
pas été retrouvé
parmi les victimes de cet attentat
figure donc l'un des hauts dignitaires
du schisme l'ayatollah mohammad baqer
hakim farouchement opposé aux attaques
anti américaines son propre frère cgt au
conseil du gouvernement irakien mise en
place par les états unis à travers lui
c'est toute une communauté qui est
atteinte certains y voient même un
avertissement à ceux qui entretiendrait
des liens avec le pouvoir soutenu par
les américains quand son père
l'ayatollah hakim à son arrivée hier à
la mosquée encadrés par ses gardes du
corps
voici les images de son dernier prêche
dans le mausolée d'ali le plus grand
lieu saint des six dans le monde une
nouvelle fois devant les fidèles
il critique les partisans de saddam
hussein auteur d' attaques contre les
américains
quelques minutes après la fin des
prières c'est l'attentât deux véhicules
bourrés d'explosifs placée juste à la
sortie de la mosquée ayatollahs hakim se
savait menacé mais l'opération d'hier
avec plus de 700 kg d'explosifs ne lui a
laissé aucune chance
depuis son retour triomphal en irak en
mai dernier après 23 ans d'exil en iran
ce très grand dignitaire chiite vivait
en permanence haute protection des
centaines de milliers de fidèles avaient
acclamé lors de son retour de ses prises
de position lui valait beaucoup
d'ennemis chef du conseil suprême de la
révolution islamique en irak
l'ayatollah hakim prônait une résistance
pacifique par rapport à l'occupation
américaine et les américains comptait
énormément sur lui pour la
reconstruction du pays
il avait besoin de lui pour s'allier la
communauté chiite
résistant de la première heure à saddam
hussein l'ayatollah était devenu un des
éléments clés de la stabilisation miral
sa disparition est aujourd'hui une
grande perte dont il est difficile de
mesurer toutes les conséquences
en tout cas après les attentats contre
l'ambassade de jordanie
le siège de l'onu l'assassinât de ce
pilier de la communauté chiite
représente incontestablement un très
sérieux revers pour la politique
américaine en irak
puis toujours en irak un oléoduc dans le
nord du pays à kirkouk est en feu il
pourrait s'agir d'un acte de sabotage
pour maîtriser l'incendié les vannes ont
été fermées
mais il faudra un ou deux jours d'après
les spécialistes pour arriver à éteindre
le feu en france spectaculaire explosion
ce matin l'aube à villefranche sur saône
une fuite de gaz a entièrement détruit
deux maisons éventrées une troisième de
personnes sont gravement blessé il
s'agit de personnes âgées qui sont resté
enseveli pendant des heures car inkomazi
une fuite de gaz et c'est l'effondrement
il n'est pas encore cette heure ce matin
quand les habitants de ce quartier de
villefranche sur saône se réveille dans
un vacarme assourdissant posions énorme
énorme énorme et un grand nuage noir
s'est abattue j'ai cru à un orage le
bilan tient du miracle
un blessé léger et deux personnes
coincées sous leur maison dans l'odeur
de gaz de fumées des chiens peine à
localiser les deux victimes
en milieu de matinée un homme de 77 ans
est extrait des décombres avec de
multiples fractures
les chiens ont pu localiser
manifestement une deuxième personne avec
qui il semble être ensevelis sous les
grands pas également et nous
elle après six heures de recherches et
d'efforts une dame âgée de 81 ans est
emmené à l'hôpital entre la vie et la
mort ce soir 10 de ses voisins sont
privées de logement d'autres de leur
voiture un moindre mal vu la puissance
de l'explosion c'est arrivé juste au
moment je dirais bien où la ville se
réveille
on se lève et
le sait
rare mais pas exceptionnelle la police a
mené son enquête sur ce qui est
probablement un accident quant aux
services de gaz de france il leur faudra
travailler dimanche à raccorder 1500
foyers
le retour des incendies en corse depuis
hier de 1500 hectares avalés par les
flammes dans une zone montagneuse sur
place un millier d'hommes appuyés par
des bombardiers d'eau sont arrivés à
venir à bout de l'incendié même si
certains foyers ne sont ne semble pas
totalement maîtrise est sur place
jacques cardoze et allemagne un ballet
incessant toute la journée ces
hélicoptères ont prêté main forte aux
moyens aériens classiques de la sécurité
civile face aux nombreux départs de feux
ces hélicoptères capables d'emporter 600
litres d'eau et coop là où ils peuvent
c'est à dire dans six rivières coincé
entre deux massifs montagneux
aujourd'hui de nombreuses mises à feu
ont été constatés dans plusieurs
secteurs de l'île
en plus des moyens aériens 600
militaires reste mobilisé des moyens
exceptionnels ont été mis en place la
prochaine journée à risques tant sur le
plan terrestre sur le plan aérien
cette nuit l'incendié s'est étendu sur
une vingtaine de kilomètres
il a ravagé des forêts de chênes de pins
et de maquis les flammes ont traversé
les habitations entourant des villages
compliquant aussi l'analyse des cintres
larcher après cet échange nervosité et
lassitude des habitants un moment
évacuées
cette région est la proie des flammes
quasiment chaque année
ce matin le maire de la commune touchée
ne pouvait que constater il s'interroge
sur les motivations des incendiaires et
les raisons sont souvent connus vous
avez des pires emballe ses allures d des
malades du feu ça existe vous avez des
intérêts liés à la chasse des intérêts
lire les petits intérêts liés à
l'élevage etc
c'était de ça qu'il faut revoir une
nouvelle politique qui est qui est à
mettre en place car on ne peut pas
accepter pour servir de petits intérêts
dérisoire de mettre en danger des
populations entières
en fin de journée les canadairs ont
repris leur envol dans une île où près
de 3000 600 hectares sont à surveiller
ici c'est une forêt de balagne qui a été
victime des incendiaires
si les pompiers combattent le feu depuis
le début de l'été ils savent aussi que
la période actuelle est propice aux feux
d'origine criminelle fin août début
septembre le vent se lève et toutes les
conditions sont réunies pour que le feu
ravage les cultures
deux autres incendies ont détruit et la
route balagne 500 hectares de forêt le
feu poussé par les flammes continue sa
progression
enfin autre feu détruit 600 hectares des
moyens supplémentaires pour est arrivé
du continent encore ce toujours après la
conférence de presse tenue hier par la
famille colonna dans laquelle les
proches de l'assassin présumé du préfet
erignac remercié tous ceux qui l'avaient
aidé pendant sa cavale
nicolas sarkozy a brièvement réagi nous
l'écoutons avec les provocations
c'est nous pas y répondre
les faits
toujours les faits donc on les fait
sue colonna est devant la justice de son
pays c'est à lui de répondre une
surenchère tout de même les faits
toujours l'effet encore les faits croyez
moi les semaines qui viennent dans
lequel je leur parlais tout ça à
quelques jours de la rentrée scolaire
nul ne sait encore si le mouvement des
enseignants reprendra après les grèves
du printemps dernier la journée de lundi
sera consacrée à une série d'assemblées
générales qui se tiendront dans la
plupart des établissements à l'appel des
syndicats
dès aujourd'hui à paris le temps était
donné avec collage d'affichés
rassemblement reportage nabiha taboury
jean-marc notebook ou de colle et
affiche sous le bras à trois jours de la
rentrée
ces enseignants reprennent leurs
habitudes revendicatrice aux abords des
écoles leur objectif est clair rappeler
que leurs mots d'ordre sont toujours
d'actualité même après deux mois de
vacances
cette rentrée on peut penser qu'il y
aura vingt mille et d'éducateurs fin
surveillants vingt mille personnes pour
encadrer les élèves en moins dans les
établissements scolaires des enseignants
aussi des milliers d'enseignants aussi
en moins des effectifs très chargé dans
les classes 4000 assistants d'éducation
supplémentaires 1500 postes pour le
premier degré et une hausse du budget de
l'éducation
durant l'été le gouvernement a fait des
gestes insuffisant selon les syndicats
après on va être pris si on démarre pas
une grève très vite après on va être
pris part comme d'habitude et emploi du
temps les machins tout le début donc je
pense que aller très vite voilà ils
étaient plus d'une centaine cet après
midi à tenter de réorganiser le
mouvement de protestation du printemps
dernier disparition d'une partie des
éducateurs et des surveillants
décentralisation les revendications ne
manquent pas le mouvement l'année
dernière il a laissé des traces dans les
esprits des liens matériels et ça ça
peut se réactiver vite ils n'ont pas
encore eu leur fiche de paie de juillet
et d'août
mais beaucoup de ces enseignants qui ont
fait grève ont déjà des retenues de
salaire jusqu'à 500 euros pour certains
je pense pas que c'est ça qui va faire
changer d'avis sur le fond les collègues
ce n'est pas par ce type de méthodes qu
on convainc les gens certainement pas et
je crois qu'après on peut moins ils
peuvent toujours après nous parler de
dialogue social de concertation et c'est
l'un des assemblées générales dans les
établissements mercredi manifestation
devant les rectorats
c'est en début de semaine qu'on mesurera
la mobilisation des enseignants douze
millions d'élèves vont donc reprendre le
chemin de l'école ce samedi était
souvent consacrée aux derniers achats
on a fait le plein des fournitures
scolaires comme le montre ce reportage
de bruno timsit des cartouches bleus à
l'effaceur
le compte y est presque mais la liste
est longue
d'autant qu'il faut faire vite la
rentrée c'est dans trois jours dans ces
conditions il s'agit d'être efficace
rien de mieux pour cela que le travail
des kits
ce que j'en viendrais
d'accord en format dans les rayons
papeterie c'est le moment fort de
l'année
quand les parents reçoivent les listes
de fournitures il ya en fait deux
tendances qui a les achats dernière
minute pour ceux qui ont commencé à
préparer leur liste jusqu'à certaines
écoles ont pris ont déjà commencé la
rentrée scolaire en début de semaine ou
alors c'est les gens qui sont rentrés un
petit peu tard de vacances et qui se
prépare pour la rentrée la semaine
prochaine et ce n'est pas fini car
souvent les professeurs complète les
listes une fois la rentrée passée il
faudra donc refaire encore un tour dans
les rayons
cette information concerne les fumeurs
et provoque la colère des débitants de
tabac les fabricants de cigarettes ont
annoncé hier une augmentation de 18 à
20% du prix du paquet afin de répercuter
la hausse des taxations votée par le
parlement cet été lors ans de leur que
sans nos fumées coûte décidément de plus
en plus cher les fabricants de
cigarettes viennent en effet d'annoncer
une hausse spectaculaire de leurs prix
le paquet pour écouter 18 à 20% de plus
soit environ 70 centimes supplémentaires
pourquoi une telle augmentation les
industriels répercutent en fait sur
leurs prix la hausse de deux taxes
prélevées par l'état hausse votée par le
parlement le 31 juillet dernier
on se comprend plus ou moins mais bon
c'est vrai que ça commence
c'est scandaleux que des entreprises
multinationales qui font déjà des
bénéfices conséquents accroissent leurs
bénéfices sur notre dos quand les
débitants de tabac à eux aussi sont en
colère baisse des ventes prix inférieurs
chez nos voisins européens développement
de la contrebande
inquiets pour leur commerce ils menacent
de descendre dans la rue aujourd'hui
le gouvernement nous met en pleine tête
deux mois de temps ils sachent sanitaire
le message sanitaire la loi les moins de
16 ans + 20 % d'augmentation
qu'est ce que vont devenir les débutants
face à cette réaction le ministère des
finances a repoussé cette hausse du prix
des cigarettes d'au moins un mois le
temps de rencontrer les représentants
des diverses professions et d'essayer
d'éviter un conflit social de plus dès
la rentrée la france mauvais élèves de
l'europe avec un déficit public pour
2003 qui devrait s'élever à 3 9%
largement au dessus des limites fixées
par le pacte de stabilité nathalie
moisan à bruxelles mercredi jean pierre
raffarin a plaidé l'indulgence
l'europe exige un déficit public
inférieur à 3% du pib le déficit
français atteindrait 3 9% pour le
gouvernement et sa majorité c'est la
croissance en panne qui crée le déficit
il faut la relance et en poursuivant les
baisses d'impôt c'est possible à une
condition on s'engage vis à vis des
autres pays européens
lorsque les recettes reviendront de les
affecter automatiquement à la baisse des
déficits
analyse opposé au parti socialiste là on
considère que ce sont précisément les
baisses d'impôts qui alimente le déficit
ce qui est dans le collimateur en
réalité sur les baisses d'impôts
voulue par jacques chirac est poursuivi
de manière entêté et absurde absurde et
parce que on voit bien que ça ne sert
que quelques favoriser sans pour autant
soutenir la croissance la france n'est
pas la seule mauvaise élève l'allemagne
aussi là se filer son déficit à 3 8% de
son pib
une situation embarrassante vis-à-vis
des partenaires européens plus vertueux
il faut que la france envoie quand même
un signal à la fois ses partenaires
européens et puis à ses petits-enfants à
elle parce que derrière les déficits ya
la dette publique est derrière la dette
il ya des impôts pour demain pourtant la
france aura du mal à rentrer dans les
clous avant 2006 a d'ores et déjà
annoncé le gouvernement
l'allemagne elle l'a pense y parvenir
dès l'an prochain
il flotte bien à un air de rentrée les
français sont de retour et en majorité
se disent pessimistes pour l'avenir si
l'on en croit ce sondage ifop dimanche
ouest france
59% des français n'ont pas le moral en
pensant à l'avenir pour eux et leurs
enfants contre 40% d'opinions optimistes
l'an passé une même enquête donne et 65%
de français
confiant dans l'avenir la suite de
l'université d'été du parti socialiste à
la rochelle en ordre de marche avec
comme programme l'opposition résolue au
gouvernement dans les allées un électron
libre bernard kouchner qui revendique sa
capacité à sortir des rangs reportage
j'évite heimberg chaque gérard c'était
le couac de l'été ps à la différence de
ses camarades bernard kouchner avait
refusé de mettre en cause le
gouvernement au sujet de la canicule
meurtrière
aujourd'hui il savait qu'on attendait de
lui des précisions
moi j'ai dit c'est un problème de
société c'est une crise humanitaire
c'est une crise de nous mêmes par
rapport aux personnes âgées
j'ai pas dit que c'était bien d'avoir
coupé le budget des personnes âgées il
n'empêche que pour beaucoup de militants
le cavalier seul de bernard kouchner qui
s'était déjà illustré au moment de la
réforme des retraites passe mal
nous militants bon bah si kouchner on
connaît comme tel et dans l'opinion
publique et
se disent ah bah c'est le parti tient il
ya des voix discordantes mais en plus ça
brouille en plus si mal et des voix
discordantes les socialistes en vol le
moins possible désormais aussi bien
lorsqu'ils défendent leur projet une
société plus solidaire quitte à demander
aux français de payer plus d'impôts que
lorsqu'il dénonce la politique actuelle
vous voyez la politique qui nous est
proposée par raffarin soufflé par chirac
c'est que chacun se démerde si vous
pouvez me permettre cette expression
vulgaire que ceux qui ont les moyens de
réussir à l'école réussissent on ne peut
pas à la fois faire des coupes
budgétaires notamment dans les dépenses
qu'ils devaient aller en direction des
personnes âgées et après c'est koné à
l'arrivée comme le numéro un des verts
gilles demers était aujourd'hui l'invité
des socialistes on n'oublie pas qu'il ya
des élections régionales dans six mois
ce sera le premier grand test pour une
gauche qui cherche toujours un nouveau
souffle depuis la rentrée politique de
françois bayrou y le président de l'udf
fera son discours de clôture de man
devant les militants rassemblés à
seignosse dans les landes pour cette
université d'été même si la question des
régionales et des européennes n'est pas
encore ouvertement évoqué françois
bayrou appelle à une grande force pour
le changement dans son pari son parti
pourrait être le noyau reportage pauline
revenant et à la location
il ya comme un air de colonies de
vacances à l'université d'été de l'udf
ils sont 800 avec un slogan un peu flou
la vérité sur tous les fronts pourtant
pas question de parler des élections
régionales mais les invités sont bien
choisies en fonction du calendrier
corinne lepage écologique n'est pas là
par hasard
au centre on fait jouer la solidarité en
dehors de lui-même
un petit mot sur la plage pour un zeste
d'écologie en vue des élections ça ne
peut pas faire de mal s'appelle
l'estacade on n'est pas là seulement
pour trouver une alliance politique je
rate les français se fichent pas mal d
alliance politique entre partis
politiques c'est pas leur problème
leur problème c'est qu'on résolve les
situations et on a envie de regrouper
des gens différents
pour qu'un jour ou l'autre les choses
changent pour mars prochain gilles de
robien annonce déjà six têtes de liste
udf françois bayrou préfère garder le
silence
demain ils se retrouvent à la tribune
l'occasion peut être d'en savoir un peu
plus après la publication des premiers
chiffres officiel et provisoire de la
surmortalité pendant la canicule
le rapport du ministère de la santé
comporte une carte géographique des
régions qui ont le plus souffert au
contraire qui ont été épargnées en rouge
sur la carte vous découvrez les
départements qui ont été le plus touchés
on retiendra que la surmortalité a été
particulièrement présente dans les
villes de paris lyon dijon et le mans en
revanche marseille toulouse rennes et
lille sont les moins touchées
la fragilité des personnes âgées face à
la canicule accentuée par la solitude
amène à une réflexion pour offrir à ces
personnes souvent dépendantes et des
mines est un moyen de communiquer avec
les secours ainsi renaud dutreil
secrétaire d'état aux pme propose un
téléphone mobile simplifié pour
l'instant il s'agit que d'une idée mais
le seul iphone pourrait avoir un avenir
s'il tient ses promesses vanille sa roue
et samuel humez les victimes de la
canicule en majorité des personnes âgées
sont pour beaucoup des cds seul à leur
domicile
peut-être que certaines auraient pu être
sauvées c'est avait tué un système d'
alerte simple à utiliser
simple comme un téléphone c'est l'idée
que vient de lancer renault du trail le
secrétaire d'état aux pme propose un
mobile conçu pour le troisième âge il
serait doté d'un écran à caractères
agrandis très lisible
en cas d' alerte trois grandes touches
d'appel des pictogrammes de couleur en
liaison directe avec les pompiers un
médecin ou un membre de la famille n'ont
proposé le sol iphone je les appelais le
sol iphone parce que il faut un
téléphone de la solidarité de la
solidarité sociale nationale mais aussi
la solidarité familiale donc un outil
qui soit à la disposition de cette belle
idée de solidarité avec nos anciens
existe déjà sur le marché by peur ou
bracelet électronique
enregistrement des allées et venues du
porteur et en cas de malaise
un bouton central déclenche un signal
d'urgence quant au sol iphone de renault
du trail les différents opérateurs de
téléphonie mobile planche actuellement
sur sa faisabilité
les nouveaux habits du train corail la
sncf a décidé de redonner confort et
modernité à ces voitures qui a
enregistré un sérieux déficit l'an passé
présentation de ce corail rénové baptisé
téoz
stéphane despinoy alexandra renard
encore des gens qui ne met pas de
ceinture de sécurité qui roule à 140 de
moyenne quand ce n'est pas en 160
remarquez vous pouvez en faire autant il
suffit de prendre le train
en trente ans le corail a eu le temps de
prendre un sérieux coup de vieux alors
pour le faire redécouvrir la sncf a
décidé de le relooker complètement
oublié le gris et l'orangé style années
le corail devient téoz le train qui ose
place au bleu à l'ocré jaune
finies aussi les rangées classique de
sièges de chaque côté il ya plus le
couloir central rectiligne le confort a
été sensiblement accrus par l'espacement
des fauteuils et puis surtout on a
surélevé le plancher si bien on a
supprimé la barre qui coupait la vue et
donc on a une vision complètement
panoramique y regarder ce paysage ces
magnifiques lumières tamisées prise
électrique en première le nouveau corps
a il n'a plus rien à envier aux tgv ne
jamais leur prend tellement le confort
était spartiate et ce train est fort
agréable nettement plus
comme si j'étais au milieu du train un
espace pour mettre les vélos mais aussi
un coin familial de chaque côté d'une
mini salle de jeu par les 276 pendant
tout le trajet
le corail retrouve ainsi une deuxième
jeunesse sur ces lignes les plus
fréquentées paris clermont ferrand dès
lundi puis paris strasbourg début 2004
mais sur d'autres lignes
le vieux corail lui est en sursis faute
de passagers
trois ans après la catastrophe du koursk
un sous marin nucléaire russe a coulé
alors qu'il était en train d'être
remorqué
neuf marins ont trouvé la mort le sous
marin avait une quarantaine d'années il
naviguait depuis 14 ans et réacteurs
nucléaires avaient été enlevées pour les
autorités il ne présente aucun danger
radioactif une nouvelle cruciale pour
les pays pauvres au terme de
négociations longues et laborieuses omc
a finalement accepté que les pays les
plus démunis est accès aux médicaments
génériques qui sont meilleur marché qui
ne savent pas fabriquer eux mêmes
alexandre kara six jours de négociations
et des mois de controverses pour enfin
parvenir à un accord sur les médicaments
génériques
depuis décembre les états unis avaient
bloqué les discussions sous la pression
du lobby pharmaceutique américain enfin
au terme d'une rencontre marathon les
pays de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce ont enfin parvenus à un
compromis
cela prouve que nous sommes capable
d'accorder les règles du commerce avec
les impératifs de l'aide humanitaire
l'accès aux médicaments bon marché une
question de vie ou de mort pour les pays
les plus pauvres surtout pour le
continent africain ravagé par l'épidémie
de sida qui compte aujourd'hui plus de
30 millions de malades
concrètement ces pays les moins
favorisés de la planète pourront
désormais importer plus facilement des
médicaments génériques meilleurs marché
si l omc on se félicite d'un accord qui
survient à moins de 15 jours du sommet
de cancun
et si l'europe et les états unis
applaudissent en revanche du côté des
organisations humanitaires on est plus
critique
médecins sans frontières considère que
cet accord ne sera pas concrètement
applicables et permet surtout de
préserver les intérêts de l'industrie
pharmaceutique des pays riches
en tout cas l'un des premiers résultats
de cet accord pourrait être d'entraîner
une baisse des prix de ces médicaments
génériques mais cela ne sera sans doute
pas suffisant pour améliorer à court
terme
situation des pays les plus touchés par
les maladies infectieuses cette journée
de samedi sur les routes de france
s'était classée rouge au total près de
240 kilomètres de bouchons autour de bio
circulation très dense 20 km de travaux
ralentissement la situation devrait se
fluidifier vers 22h ralentissement
également entre orange et bollène et
autour de vienne la circulation est
difficile également en sens des départs
contrairement à ce qui était prévu en
fin des difficultés autour de paris
l'événement sportif de ce samedi avec
plusieurs médailles d'or pour la france
aux championnats du monde d'athlétisme
d'abord l'éclatante performance de
younis barber qui s'empare de l'or en
saut en longueur et puis le rêve réalisé
par les quatre championnes vec de l'or
aussi dans le relais 4 x 100 m dans un
stade en liesse l'équipe tricolore bat
le record de france nathanaël de
rincquesen jusqu'au bout du suspense
il a fallu attendre la dernière minute
la dernière course
le dernier saut pour que nice barber
devienne championne du monde
si m 99 devant 64 mille spectateurs
déchaînés
la russe kotova son adversaire et
médusée et battu barber offre à la
france sa première médaille d'or des
championnats du monde
il était dit que cette journée serait
riche en émotions quelques minutes plus
tard au départ du 4 x 100 m patricia
girard a de l'énergie à revendre couloir
la française prend le meilleur départ tu
sais par le public
elle passe parfaitement le relais à
muriel hurtis les américaines étaient
les favorites mais privé de keyyo avec
la femme la plus rapide du monde cette
finale devient subitement plus
équilibrée virage après virage relais
après relais les deux nations sont au
coude à coude
à l'issue du dernier relais christine
arron accuse pourtant quelques mètres de
retard mais il en fallait plus pour
empêcher la française de franchir en
tête la ligne d'arrivée
ça y est c'est fait elles sont
championnes du monde avec deux médailles
d'or en moins d'une heure la france
vient de vivre une de ses plus belles
soirées l'athlétisme
le nice barber je vous retrouve en
direct du stade de france bonsoir et
bravo pour cette médaille d'or est ce
que vous avez repris votre souffle est
ce que vous arrivez à réaliser ah là là
peut-être de ma vie mais lasses
commencer si le rêve quoi
là c'était fantastique et je vais gérer
à l'histoire encore il faut que je
revoie sa vous allez le revoir sur les
images vous allez vous repasser votre
notre perfection exactement parce que
mon coach croyait en moi
il savait que gégé 17 m dans les jambes
mais d'investisseurs je savais pas
contre cette performance va arriver dans
les jambes mais le dernier solo public
était formidable je me suis dit il faut
tout donner je n'ai rien à perdre et
vraiment ça me fait plaisir de reprise
ça toute la france tout les gens qui
tombent à l'eau et derrière il suffit de
l'oreillette le rôle est quoi oui on va
on va voir peut être avec les
championnes du relais peut-être on les
aura en direct ionis vous avez été
d'elena elles sont la glace au juste
derrière mais ne m'attendent pas encore
yanis vous avez été blessé je crois il
ya deux ans il n'avait jamais douté
non je n'ai jamais dit c'est parce que
la vie c'est comme ça moi dans ma
perception des choses c'est comme le
moment c'est dur c'est le mot que j'ai
envie de réussir est vraiment j'ai tout
donné pour arriver à là pour me soigner
tous les matins c'est c'est d'aller à la
salpêtrière à l'essai pour faire des
soins je croyais vraiment métal on est
vraiment jamais fait plaisir de réaliser
ça dévoile au public français
c'est un plaisir qu'on partage largement
avec vous vous avez tout juste à vos
côtés muriel hurtis qui ne m'entends pas
elles savent que vous allez pouvoir
m'aider et lui poser une question qui
demandait d'abarth la première réaction
c'est vrai c'est quoi on est très
heureux c'est vrai que tout les cats on
voulait cette médaille on voulait monter
sa première marche du podium et ont une
superbe course qu'on a fait
tous ensemble et on est on est tout
content tu sais quoi dans sa question je
voudrais savoir si c'est peut-être elle
aussi quelle est cette joie qui les
apportaient à gagner est ce qu'elle
avait un moral de gagnant tel ne pouvait
pas perdre
et puis c'est une double performance
avait quand même à un record qui est en
plus le record de france la médaille
d'or elle record vous avez un moral de
gagnant et en plus ça le record de
france
ah oui bien sûr là il fallait la voir on
l'a montré on était on était venus pour
conquérir on à conquérir devant notre
public donc on est super content s'est
même pas des gagnantes en alsace et des
guerrières finalement partis au combat
et on n'a rien lâché sur chaque match at
the sack massa sur sa cause n'a vraiment
s'est donné à fond et moi j'avais
l'americana côté je me suis dit je vais
vraiment rien laisser aller vraiment
cher
patricia giroux et c'est clair au départ
il fallait rien lâcher je suis arrivé
tout est possible si muriel et là je les
regardais j'aime peu délavé je me disais
ça va le faire ça va 100 ça va le faire
et on l'a gagnée on voulait cette
médaille c'est l'essentiel
alors une dernière question ionis à vous
tout au fond au guerrière que me comme
dit christine à qui vous désirez ses
victoires à thibout dit vous dédié ce
big 3 la famille moi la musique est un
type formidable et ça c'est bon pour le
public mais elle est négative et vous
avez entendu moi j'ai dédié à tous les
gens qui m'ont fait confiance le public
français est vraiment c'est fantastique
on a fait la fête toute la on va bien
bravo bravo à la fouille et vous avez
bien mérité de faire la fête et c'est
vrai que si dix ans est avec vous et
très heureux pour vous ce succès
formidable formidable d'avoir répondu en
direct à nos questions passons au rugby
avec ce soir à 21h à marseille le match
amical france angleterre à six semaines
du début de la coupe du monde d'un test
important pour le quinze de france sait
c'est le stade vélodrome temple du
ballon rond qui accueille le ballon
ovale
ambiance avant le coup d'envoi
christophe duchiron d'heure numério
c'est à marseille aux portes du stade
c'est la foule des grands jours et c'est
un match de rugby à marseille où le
quinze de france n'a jamais perdu une
rencontre marseille dont certains
voudraient faire la capitale du rugby
très bon public bons supporters mieux
qu'à paris
alors on dirait à bernard laporte qui
viennent jouer ici parce qu'il ya la
mare de monter à paris
ça nous coûte trop cher pour les photos
de vacances il faudra voir plus tard car
cette semaine les bleus n'ont pas fait
bronzette non les bleus ils ont
poursuivi leur préparation en répétant
leur rugby et accessoirement déchirant
leur maillot et c'est une heureuse
coïncidence car l'équipementier du
quinze de france a mis au point une
sorte de nec plus ultra du prêt-à-porter
rugbystique un truc près du corps super
mou lent mais croyons que c'est fait
exprès c'est pour empêcher la main
baladeuse de l'adversaire qui voudra
trappe et un bleu par le maillot à part
ça hier l'équipe de france est venu en
repérage au stade vélodrome ce temple du
foot où depuis quelques années le ballon
rond les sentiments terrain libre à
l'ovale
on est toujours très bien accueillis à
l'image de son vol super mais public une
ambiance toujours très très chaude donc
c'est c'est d'autant plus agréable pour
nous qui sont sur le terrain et puis ça
nous ça nous pousse dans les moments un
peu difficiles d'accord marseille reste
avant tout la ville de l'om de la bonne
mère de la bouillabaisse et du vieux
port mais ce week-end au bord de la
méditerranée
il avait tournoi de rugby de plage
marseille a donné zizou à la france du
foot
alors à quand une star du rugby en
direct du stade vélodrome nous
retrouvons pierre salviac et thierry
lacroix
les supporteurs dans le stade de l'om
c'est déjà un atout pour les quinze de
france bien sûr béa et vous aussi par la
même occasion marseille la ville qui
m'émerveille pour cette affiche
extra verdict d'une finale de coupe du
monde ce soir entre l'équipe de france
et l'équipe d'angleterre d'auto peut
dire qu'elle est aujourd'hui thierry la
croire la meilleure équipe du monde
alors question est ce que l'équipe de
france peut la battre ce soir spgo
effectuant pierre rappelons quand même
que la france a battu les meilleures
nations au monde australie afrique du
sud
nouvelle zélande elle n'a jamais perdu à
marseille maintenant il faudra
transpercé ce fameux rideau blanc vous
verrez sur votre écran et la soitec a
pas de le faire une fois vous plus
enlevée je veux demander vous à partir
de 20h50 choisi nous y serons et nous
est censé ainsi se termine ce journal
dans un instant la météo isabelle
martinet fadeur 50-55 donc le rugby 1h25
le dernier journal jean claude renaud
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain dès 13 heures je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée
oh